contamos los votos y hay un ganador y un
perdedor esto es lo que sucederá
contaremos los votos y terminaremos con
el resultado y será preciso así que
continuaremos dándoles información
mientras ésta se vuelve disponible
estamos trabajando en este tema todos
están trabajando en esto puedes ver el
streaming en vivo la gente está
trabajando apenas tengamos los números
les haremos saber no no hay
problemáticas
no estamos avanzando
a las 353 vamos a actualizar todos estos
números en algún punto del día de hoy
no sé en este momento
buenas cuando los siguientes totales
salgan serán parte del número original
que tengamos aún no hemos llegado allá
estamos aún contando las balotas
voy a dejar que el comisionado el
comisionado de smith diga lo que tenga
que decir esto definitivamente no es
cierto lo que sí puedo decir es que le
decimos a la prensa que pregunte cuántas
papeletas se pueden contar a toda
velocidad sin interrupción y decimos
si esto pasa no significa que son
capaces de contar 10.000 papeletas esto
cambia
tenemos estaciones de trabajo y tenemos
que limpiar entre cada turno y turno
y si al menos hasta esta hora mañana
entonces la mitad de las personas en
este salón dicen escucha no van a saber
los resultados en el día de elección
tienen que tener un abordaje diferente
una perspectiva diferente las reglas han
cambiado con la balota por correo hay
muchos votos que se hacen por correo por
ende contar estos votos por correo si se
hace bien y si se hace con precisión
porque no hay otra forma de hacer las
cosas es algo que tomar y poco más de
tiempo yo entiendo que esto es
frustrante para ustedes para nosotros
pero si lo vamos a hacer bien y vamos a
prevenir problemas que ponen en riesgo
los votos es más importante que hagamos
las cosas bien en vez de trabajar con
plazos artificiales estamos empujando
los resultados tan rápido como podamos
no nos estamos conteniendo nada ni vamos
a media marcha si decimos 9
nosotros queremos que ustedes sepan tan
pronto como tengamos más votos para
reportar ustedes pueden ver que ellos
han estado trabajando sin interrupción
allá arriba
es algo que va en cascada lo que sucede
es como una línea de ensamblar primero
tienes las papeletas que acabaron de
ingresar están selladas
estas se preparan y después se mueven se
clasifican
después las mueven a la mesa de
atracciones donde se cuentan y donde se
extrae del sobre
y después toman el contenido de esas
papeletas y luego tienen que desdoblar
las y preparadas para el proceso de
escaneo esto toma tiempo toma tiempo
abrir tantos sobres como todos saben por
eso es que sabíamos que se iba a demorar
un poco más